bonsoir
on applaudit girl salut je viens
d'arriver en californie en général je
chante avec un ukulélé mais il y a un
début à tout
et monde qui y vivent je pensais pas
qu'on déménagerait aussi vite encore une
fois je croyais que tu aimais partir à
l'aventuré
partir à l'aventuré c'est une chose mais
que ta vie tout entière devient une
aventure ça sent une autre mais la vie
est une info tu vaux mieux c'est j'adore
comment tu chantais assez gentil je
m'appelle est bonne et moi c'est à
regarder j'adore il faut que ce qui se
passe ici c'est notre nouvelle voisine
pour soi
mon frère et moi on fait un film et il y
aura de la musique mais il nous faut une
fille et je crois que tu serais la fille
parfaite
alors tu veux jouer de notre film ok wes
mars mais non c'est roxane martèle
qu'elle a fait un album et ensuite plus
rien elle est là tous les soirs ces
tarifs des crèches au soudan j'aime les
chansons des autres et ça me suffit il
va falloir de trouver quelque chose à
toi
paris quitte à huy de 100 moines
si tout est ok c'est bon you can
les musées
bien
chose
[Musique]
tout ce que je voulais c'était rêver à
des choses insensées
où tout le monde est assez fou pour rire
est avec vous toi tu m'as apporté
quelque chose que je n'avais vu que dans
des films jusqu'ici
j'ai trouvé plus que ça
[Musique]
une chose à laquelle je m'attendais pas
non pas d un c
[Musique]
à
celle là elle était super on va faire
une pause